what's up guys so as you guys may know I
just finished my PC build series in
which I unboxed and reviewed every part
I used in it and made a time-lapse build
as well so if you guys are interested in
any of that then make sure to click the
link in the description below for the
playlist today I want to help you guys
choose the parts for your first PC and
to do that I'm going to go to all my PC
parts and explain the reasoning behind
why I chose each one and what you should
get but first before we get into the
parts list you need to first identify
why or even building a PC is it for
gaming video editing work for fun you
need to know this before you start doing
anything basically let's tell us what
level of performance you want for each
part I'm going to be going over who
should buy each level component such as
who should buy an i3 or an i-5 so let's
jump right in first of all even before
you choose a CPU you need to ask
yourself do you want a GPU if you are a
gamer then of course you would want one
but for many others a GPU is completely
unnecessary if you don't want the GPU
then the CPU choice would be an easy one
you'd want to go to Intel because it has
integrated graphics and that will always
be cheaper than it Rison
plus my graphics card and for everyone
else who does want a GPU what do you go
with Intel or Rison on the mainstream
platform this church is actually quite
simple looking at it from a money
perspective if you want the best bang
for buck and then just go with Rison on
a performance point of view if you guys
are gonna use this PC for gaming or just
daily work test it to the Microsoft
offices then you guys just go with Intel
if you guys want a powerful editing rig
or workstation PC then go with Rison
pretty much single threaded equals Intel
multi thread equals rising soil gamers
should just go straight to intone people
plan to stream however may want to
consider Rison contact queers on the
other hand should go with idle depending
on how often they create content
everyone else it's just goat in tow but
is it's still the better option for most
users due to its Excel and single
Twitter applications it's as simple as
that if you have a specific use case in
here that makes your post in the
comments down below now I'll tell you
what I think about it once you've chosen
which one of those you want let's dive
into which level to get only get the
rise in three or into I three if you are
on a very tight budget most people
should go with rise and five our Intel
i5 this gives almost everyone abundant
power and it is plenty for gaming the
only reason you should go with horizon 7
or into i7 is because you want the
absolute best on the mainstream platform
the fine series is more than RIA enough
really there may be a few of you who
actually need the 7 Series and you guys
know who you are
the i7 8700 K is the best gaming CPU out
there so if that's what you want then
that is what you should get this should
cover almost everyone for the super
power users if you guys have a big
business and make a quite a bit of money
from your PC then don't skip out and
just go with the sky like X and Intel
even though it's more expensive if you
guys make some money from your PC not
that much then you guys just stick to
the thread Ripper all of you guys who
want to go for it enthusiasts line just
because you want the best then don't cuz
it's really pointless I knew I wanted to
get into YouTube videos and I really
wanted that Sepideh of the 7 Series
provided and of course I want to the
best and that is why I went that with
the Intel i7 8700 K next ask for the CPU
cooler this is very simple as well
unless you are building a top law build
then just go with the air cooler air
coolers give almost the same if not the
same overclocking Headroom as a water
cooler so just save your money and go
with an air cooler I got the course here
H 100 IV 2 for quite a good deal and I
was building a premium system so that is
why I bought a water cooler next if
you're looking into a Jeep
you then don't get a 1050 or 1050 TI
unless you are on an extreme budget most
people should get a 1060 it is the
perfect middle ground and can handle all
modern games at 1080p at 60 frames per
second and it will last at least a
couple of years if you want to
future-proof yourself or have a 1440p
monitor or 1080p ultra wide or even
triple honours that i put three 1080p
screens then you should go with the 1070
the 1070 TI is really just an
unnecessary card and it shouldn't have
even been created if you want 4k 1440p
all too wide or super smooth triple
monitor gaming and just go straight to a
1080i 1080 TI is really only for extreme
builders are gamers who crave super
smooth 4k gaming ask for sli just don't
it's really a dying technology and it's
not worth it
after AMD get the 560 or 570 only if
you're on a very tight budget get the
580 if you want almost identical
performance to 10 60 or if you are
getting attend a free sink water the 580
and 1060 are pretty much the same but
the freezing waters are much cheaper
than jisuk see if you are getting a
freezing water and he considered 580
instead of the 1060 finally Vega is just
not worth it Nvidia is still a king in
that range so don't buy Baker the
motherboard
really comes down to brand loyalty or
budget if you want the most premium
board that in my opinion I think Asus
makes the best motherboards if you're
getting a rise in three or into i3 then
I recommend that you guys go with the
budget motherboard from MSI gigabyte or
ass rock if you guys are getting I 5 or
rise in 5 and I recommend that you guys
still get MSI gigabyte or asrock
motherboard because they provide you
with everything you really need if you
guys are getting I 7 horizon 7 yeah you
obviously want the best and you guys
should look into the higher-end MSI or
gigabyte ports or the entry-level rog
boards from Asus don't buy a crazy
extreme board like the Asus of Maximus
or MSI Garlin motherboards because they
are really pointless
since I got an i7 I went with an
entry-level ROG Strix boy from Asus RAM
is really overpriced right now so I
recommend you just get the cheapest rent
available at suspects that you are
looking for if you are getting rising
just make sure that the RAM you choose
is fully compatible without the full
speed with rising only go with the cool
Ram like Ram with RGB like I did if
you're getting an i7 or rising seven I
found a good deal on course your RGB on
Black Friday so I snatched it at $169
but otherwise just get normal RAM
storage is also really simple most
everyone should get a hard drive with a
couple of terabytes of storage and SSD
with about 250 gigabytes of space for
the hard drive I recommend you guys get
a Seagate Barracuda series or the
Western Digital blue hard drives ask for
SSD if you are on a budget then get the
cheapest one available with SSDs deliver
quite similar performance and you
probably wouldn't even notice the
difference don't skimp on the SSD not
buy one because it really is a day and
night difference between a hard drive
nvme is like an i7 it's really not
necessary wait if you want the best then
just get to the samsung 960 Evo don't go
for the pro unless you actually are
professional who would take advantage of
it
next get a power supply that is rated at
100 to 150 watts over your estimated
wattage required this should give plenty
of overclocking Headroom as for brand I
would recommend to EVGA or Corsair
depending on whichever one is cheaper
when you are buying window is just good
windows home you really don't need
Windows 10 Pro finally the case this is
possibly the most subjective thing on
this list unless you have an extreme
build I recommend you go with a normal
case for $100 or less there are some
great cases that even have RGB and
tempered glass in that range
if you have an extreme bill then yes you
should go with the case and $100 to $200
range with crazy RGB art and tempered
glass if that's what you want don't go
for a case over $200 however it really
just does not make sense it's literally
just a box usually case fans are not
very useful they're really just to give
your build a bit more spicy seriously
your case probably comes with enough
fans and a negative or positive air
pressure system inside your PC won't
really do anything to your PC so get
Keys fans only if you want them next
outside your PC you're going to need a
monitor I recommend to get a good
monitor with 60 Hertz and 1080p with
good colors anymore it'sjust reformer
finally peripherals are really just
preference you really only need a decent
headset like the Logitech G 430 which is
actually really good for its price and
there are plenty of budget-friendly
gaming mice they really just need that
Coolermaster can Meccano keyboard for
$80 to $90 anything more than that and
just don't want and it's really just for
fun just make sure that you spend any
money on your peripherals does not make
you have to downgrade any of your other
PC parts well guys if you guys are still
here
then thanks for sticking around I hope
that this hopes you guys choose what
parts you actually need or want as
always if you have any questions then
make sure to leave them in a comment
section down below
I read all my comments so I will respond
to your questions to the best of my
ability that's all I have for you guys
this time if you guys like to video this
video to make sure to drop me a like if
you guys loved it and would like to see
more videos just like this then make
sure to subscribe and hit double
notification but that's all I have for
you guys this time until next video bye